[Musique]
merci Daniel grémier de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu dévog MRE du groupe les
républiquains vice-président de la
commission des affaires économiques et
rapporteur du budget de l'écologie dont
on va parler dans quelques instants
d'abord on l'a vu dans le journal les
suites de l'attaque terroriste à Paris
laassillant toujours en garde à vue
Gérald armanin qui vous l'avez entendu
estime que les autorités ont fait le
maximum dans le cadre de la loi mais qui
a eu un ratage psychiatrique vous
partagez ça al j'irais pas jusqu'à dire
un ratage
psychiatrique il est vrai qu'au niveau
de notre pays globalement notre système
de santé en grande souffrance et on est
on a une situation au niveau de la
psychiatrie très très alarmante et je le
vis moi-même dans le département des
vaoges mais pas que dans tous les
départements on a une situation de
manque de soignant d'accompagnement des
des personnes qui sont en souffrance il
y a un vrai sujet mais sur ce point
parti particulier le Sénat avec
notamment un texte qui a été proposé par
Jean Noël buffet qui qui consistait tout
simplement à qui a été voté au Sénat qui
a renforcé qui a proposé qui proposait
tout simplement de de dire il doit y
avoir un système de la près c'està-dire
que lorsque un individu qui a été
condamné pour terrorisme acte de
terrorisme ou de prévision d'acte de
terrorisme doit avoir un suivi lorsqu'il
est sorti de de rétention c'est quand
même dommage que l'Assemblée nationale
jusqu'à présent n''est pas repris ce
texte ce texte été voté au Sénat il
avait renforcé effectivement ce suivi
lorsqu'on est sorti de ça c'est pour les
les radicalisés qui sortent de prison on
va y venir mais sur le côté
psychiatrique Géral armmanin il en
appelle au Parlement il veut que les
autorités puissent prononcer des
injonctions de soins est-ce que vous
êtes favorable bah il est évident que
lorsqu'on est dans une
situation qui peut-être aggravante pour
la la société en terme de risque
l'obligation de se soigner est quelque
chose qui doit être entendu c'est un
vrai sujet effectivement parce que vous
êtes prêt à soutenir le ministre de
l'Intérieur là c'est un sujet qu'il faut
regarder avec une grande lucidité une
grande responsabilité dès lors
qu'effectivement que c'est cette
situation est avérée sur le suivi vous
en avez parlé hein le suivi des des
radicalisés sortant en prison il y avait
eu un premier texte porté par yelbrun
pivé et et par Jacqueline stagebgot
votre collègue sénatrice des
républicains mais qui a été retoqué par
le Conseil constitutionnelle qui jugeait
qu'il allait trop loin qui portait
notamment atteinte à à la liberté
d'aller et venir à à au droit à une vie
familiale normale il y a eu ensuite un
un second texte est-ce que pour vous la
loi aujourd'hui est suffisante sur le
suivi de ces radicalisés sortant de
prison et de ces personnes qui ont fait
de la prison euh lui c'était pour
préparation d'un acte terroriste non
c'est d'ailleurs ça fait partie de tous
les sujets qui ont été mis sur la table
et qui ont été vraiment bien travaillés
par le Sénat et on l'a encore vu sur le
dernier texes de la loi immigration qui
est d'ailleurs en discussion un peu
complexe à l'Assemblée euh où nous avons
effectivement renforcé l'arsenal il
existe déjà beaucoup je serais tenté de
dire si on appliquait déjà les lois avec
une grande clarté mais aussi une grande
efficacité on aurait déjà fait un bout
du chemin mais il est nécessaire d'aller
plus loin d'où là d'ailleurs les
propositions du Sénat d'une réforme
constitutionnelle dans le sur ce point
particulier sur la loi immigration
puisque vous en parlez là encore Gérald
armmanin qui était au 20h dimanche soir
il en appelle au parlementaires
notamment au parlementaires les
républicains et un appel à la
responsabilité pour voter son texte et
il dit attention si un prochain acte est
commis par un étranger et que ce texte
n'a pas été voté oui je serais tenté de
dire au ministre de l'Intérieur euh
qu'il l'œuvre aussi en fonction du
travail qui a été réalisé au Sénat un
travail très responsable qui a été très
apprécié j'ai beaucoup de r tour euh de
nos concitoyens sur le travail
sénatorial sur ce texte là et
effectivement il appartient aussi au
ministre de faire en sorte que cette
colonne vertébrale qui permet d'apporter
plus de sécurité en la matière soit
aussi que ce travail sénatorial ne soit
pas démonté je serais tenté de dire la
responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur n'est pas dans un sens il
s'agit aussi de garder une une
architecture bien équilibrée telle
qu'elle est sortie du Sénat euh et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les députés sont
peut-être un peu en train de mal
l'amener un dernier mot là-dessus
puisque certains à droite et au
rassemblement national Jordan Bardell
mis le débat sur la table réclame la
rétention de sûreté c'est-à-dire pouvoir
garder des gens en prison une fois
qu'ils ont exécutter leur peine parce
qu'ils sont encore considérés comme
dangereux est-ce que c'est la bonne
piste je pense que la piste là est fait
peut-être des parti des piste à étudier
dans les propositions que qui ont été
faites au niveau de la PPL Jean Noël
buffet on va plus loin d'une manière
plus responsable encore puisque on met
on propose un arsenal de suivi de la
personne qui sort de rétention le suivi
ne veut pas dire forcément
rétention et et c'est là la différence
avec la proposition que vous évoquez on
va parler de ce qui se passe au Sénat
puisque vous poursuivez l'examen du
budget hier é examiné le budget de
l'écologie vous êtes le rapporteur on va
parler de tout ça avec Quentin
calm
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour orien bonjour
Daniel gremier bonjour et Quentin le
Sénat poursuit donc l'examen du budget
alors après le vote des crédits sécurité
des crédits immigration les sénateurs
ont examiné le volet environnement et
surtout énergie voilà c'est ça un sujet
majeur de ce projet de loi de finance
dans le contexte de l'inflation
généralisé les dépenses énergétiques que
ce soit le gaz l'électricité le file
tout cela ça'appelle PSE lourd depuis 2
ans dans le porte-monnaie dans le budget
des Français d'ailleurs le poids de ces
factures notamment d'électricité dans le
quotidien des Français ça a été rappelé
en séance écoutez le sénateur Fran
Montauger en 3 ans nos compatriotes vont
avoir payé 33 % de
plus en matière d'énergie électrique on
aura eu une augmentation de près
d'un/ers de la facture pour les mêmes
quantités
d'énergie acheté voilà en plus des
difficultés liées à
l'inflation pardon à l'alimentation même
même phénomène que l'on peut constater
au transport au
logement
situation catastrophique extrêmement
difficile pour de très très nombreuses
familles françaises c'est ça la réalité
et justement Quentin dans ce contexte
comment accompagner la fin des boucliers
énergétiques pour les particuliers et
ben c'est tout l'enjeu effectivement la
fin de ces boucliers cétait tout l'enjeu
notamment du débat hier en séance même
cela a été l'occasion d'une passe
d'armes entre les sénateurs LR et le
gouvernement depuis une semaine et le
début de l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financeces tout le monde cherche à faire
des économies on l'a bien compris le
gouvernement a beaucoup miser sur la fin
de ces boucliers énergétiques sauf celui
sur l'électricité des ménages mais les
sénateurs de droite et du cent ont
proposé de faire des économies 1
milliard d'euros d'économie en
supprimant plutôt que prévu vu le
bouclier sur l'électricité pour tous les
Français avec un système de chèque pour
les plus modestes et les classes
moyennes c'est-à-dire pour 60 % des
Français disent les sénateurs écoutez
les explications de la rapporteur
spéciale Christine Lavarde on a 150
milliards de déficit alors on vient
juste vous aider à avoir un déficit un
tout petit peu moindre à la fin de
l'année par un dispositif ciblé et c'est
responsable parce qu'on pourrait faire
comme vous continuez comme dirait le
sable le rapporteur général arroser le
sable chaud mais ça ne sert à rien ouais
c'est sénateur qui explique que les
ménages les plus aisés peuvent réduire
leur consommation d'électricité face à
la hausse des tarifs qui en
découleraient le gouvernement n'est pas
du tout d'accord avec cette idée et
conteste l'analyse du Sénat pour les
ministres ce mécanisme des sénateurs
reviendrait à faire grimper la facture
de plus 20 % l'année prochaine écoutez
la ministre anes panerunaché on a une
ligne très claire depuis le début depuis
le début et qui a été annoncé très
clairement par Bruno Lemire et moi-même
les tarifs de l'électricité
n'augmenteront pas de plus de 10 %.
c'est ça la ligne elle est tenue et
aujourd'hui les prix sur les marché nous
permettent de confirmer que nous allons
progressivement sortir du bouclier
énergétique et nous le faisons en bon
ordre et sans matraquer les Français
alors Daniel grimier c'est c'est un
débat qui peut très rapidement être très
technique donc on va pas rentrer dans
les acronymes de de toutes ces taxes sur
lesquelles veut jouer le Sénat et cetera
mais comment comprendre la réticence du
gouvernement à rendre ce dispositif plus
ciblé Chine lavard a parlé d'un effet
d'ben massif avec le dispositif actuel
comment est-ce que vous comprenez la
position du gouvernement écoutez il y a
deux choses effectivement sans rentrer
dans ce schéma très complexe de
l'architecture du du prix prix
d'électricité exactement mais un chiffre
en 10 ans l'électricité pour un ménage a
pris 70 % en 10 ans donc on avait déjà
une situation de croissance du prix de
l'énergie bien avant la pandémie euh la
pandémie à la reprise l'a amplifié et et
on paye cche complètement l'inaction du
gouvernement des gouvernements sur
l'énergie sur le nucléaire notamment la
dégradation de notre parc nucléère
générale sur l'énergie c'estd l'énergie
qui est qu'on garantit de
fournir mon propos n'est pas d'être
contre le renouvelable il nous faut
intensifier nos investissements dans le
renouvelable mais il nous faut aussi une
colonne vertébrale une sécurité
d'approvisionnement et la seule sécurité
c'est effectivement le nucléaire c'est
les centrales à charbon ou au gaz en
Allemagne non mais je le dis parce que
nous avons décidé en France de les
fermer c'est exemplaire d'ailleurs on en
reparlera par rapport au budget parce
que les territoires qui les ont fermés
sont un peu abandonnés et j'ai souhaité
avoir des engagements précis du
gouvernement pour accompagner ces
territoires c'est la fermeture de la
centrale de F mais regardons la
perspective la ministre a évoqué les
perspectives euh du futur sur le prix de
l'énergie et notamment faisait référence
aux annonces à la fois du ministre de
l'économie et des finances et et
d'elle-même sur un prix qui pourrait
passer à 70 aujourd'hui on est à 42 au
niveau je fais je parle la fin du
système de l'arinene du du du du système
dans lequel nous nous trouvons euh c'est
à nouveau plus de 60 % d'augmentation du
prix de l'énergie en terme de
perspective et euh aujourd'hui euh il
est vraiment vraiment nécessaire euh que
la France garde cette capacité de
production énergétique qu'on retrouve
notre indépendance notre sécurité
n'oublions pas que le prix de l'énergie
a été la colonne vertébrale de vie pour
les ménages mais aussi pour l'industrie
française on aurait pas eu ce prix-l on
serait pas dans cette situation alors
pour revenir à ce qui s'est passé hier
en séance il y a donc ce bouclier sur
l'électricité pour tous les Français le
Sénat veut y mettre fin plus rapidement
que le gouvernement avec un système de
chèque ça le gouvernement n'en veut pas
comment est-ce que vous comprenez que le
gouvernement ne veit pas d'un système
plus ciblé comme le voudraient les
sénateurs ça semble être plutôt du bon
sens ben c'est parfois c'est surprenant
la position du gouvernement je vais
prendre deuxième exemple très concret
qui a été en débat aussi hier sur ma
prime renove le Sénat est ce que j'ai
présenté c'était ma primeov permet
effectivement la meilleure économie pour
les ménages c'est de ne pas dépenser
l'argent effectivement c'est d'améliorer
la rénovation énergétique plus
rapidement ça permettra d'atteindre plus
rapidement aussi les objectifs de
neutralité carbone mais pour pouvoir le
faire et pour être efficace il faut
rendre accessible plus de ménage à cette
capacité d'investissement tout le monde
n'a pas les moyens de faire une
rénovation globale et ce que je défends
c'est une rénovation étape par étape
plus accessible au niveau des foyers et
là aussi nous avons eu un débat sur
l'accessibilité euh est-ce que
l'ensemble des ménages peuvent en
bénéficier ou pas et l'aspect du revenu
est un élément essentiel à prendre en
compte l'accompagnement doit être plus
important pour celles et ceux qui sont
en situation de fragilité mais mais
quand vous entendez agè panier unché
dire qu'une augmentation de la facture
de 15 voire 20 % c'est trop important
est-ce qu'elle a pas raison mais
attention je je redis les je redonne le
chiffre nous avons en 10 ans eu 70 %
d'mentation d'énergie pourquoi je vous
rappelle quand même que si le Sénat
n'avait pas vuvré j'en étaé le
rapporteur sur le texte sur
l'accélération des énergies
nucléairirees c'est c'est c'est a qu'à
bousculer les lignes on est on était
encore sur la fermeture de 14 réacteurs
on était sur la la diminution du
nucléaire à à à 50 % et et et surtout on
était dans une situation où on a
tellement décourager les productions
énergétiques mais on on va y venir sur
le nucléaire mais là sur le prix puisque
les Français ils vont voir leur facture
en en 2024 est-ce qu'avec votre système
d'être ciblé il y a pas un risque que
les classes moyennes V leur facture
exploser non le le risque de
d'augmentation pour les classes moyennes
c'est d'un côté effectivement peut-être
un prix de l'énergie qui sera supérieure
mais une accessibilité de ces classes
moyennes alors qu'elles étaient exclues
à bénéficié du système d'accompagnement
dans les investissements qu'elles vont
réaliser sur les économies d'énergie
qu'elles vont faire parce qu'elles vont
isoler parce qu'il y a des travaux qui
vont être réalisé dans leur habitat
ouais et rendre accessible à la fois les
propriétaires bailleurs les copropriétés
effectivement on a eu aussi ce débat sur
l'énergie hier en séance parce que
beaucoup de sénateurs se sont plains
qu'on a un peu mis la charue avant les
bœ qu'on est fait ces texte sur les
énergies renouvelables celui sur le
nucléaire dont vous étiez le rapporteur
avant une grande loi de programmation de
l'énergie vous vous êtes d'accord avec
eux il manque cette vision sur notre
situation de l'énergie en France ah mais
complètement là encore c'est le Sénat
qui a été à la manœuvre puce que c'est
le Sénat qui l'a et là encore j'étais
encore rapporteur c'est nous qui avons
inscrit dans la loi l'oblig au
gouvernement d'avoir un débat
parlementaire sur la trajectoire
énergétique du pays je vous rappelle
pour que dans un pays il y a deux
éléments essentiels pour bien vivre
c'est d'avoir l'assiette donc
l'alimentation et d'avoir aussi une
énergie accessible la force de la France
ça a été pendant plusieurs décennies
d'avoir une énergie accessible et en
plus décarboné donc le sujet d'avoir une
trajectoire d'avoir un débat
parlementaire il est essentiel et je
vois que nous avons des des textes qui
arrivent les uns après les autres nous
avons eu effectivement je l'ai dit je
l'ai notre majorité sénatoriale l'a dit
à la ministre c'est on travaille dans le
désordre l'ordre aurait été
effectivement d'avoir une une PPE
d'avoir effectivement une programmation
de ce qu'on va faire en terme
énergétique en terme d'économog
pluriannuelle sur l'énergie
exactement que qui qui marie à la fois
le renouvelable et aussi les énergies
pilotables sur le nucléaire justement
puis il y a COP 28 qui se tient en ce
moment à Dubaï et une vingtaine de pays
dont les États-Unis et la France ont
appelé à tripler les capacités de
l'énergie nucléaire dans le monde d'ici
2050 par rapport à aujourd'hui vous vous
en réjouissez ben c'est c'est essentiel
et et c'est là que je comprends pas là
encore la France sans le savoir il y a
pratiquement un demi-siècle avait une
longueur d'avance on parle de décarboné
nous étions le pays au monde qui avait
le plus d'énergie décarbonée on avait 75
% d'énergie qui promenait du nucléaire
qui est décarboné et nous avions 13 %
d'énergie hydrolectrique produite avec
l'hydroélectricité qui est décarboné et
c'est quand même incroyable et et
l'enjeu de la neutralité carbone qui est
2050 qui va on va pas le réussir en
claquant dans les doigts effectivement
ça nécessite d'aller plus vite plus loin
sur la production énergétique et le
dossier électrique disons les choses on
parle d'économie d'énergie bien sûr il
faut le faire mais lorsqu'on dit la fin
du fossile de l'énergie Foss
quand on voit l'impact le la place
qu'aujourd'hui est là encore au
quotidien dans la vie des Français dans
l'économie il va falloir augmenter du
Mare significative la production
d'énergie électrique je parle même pas
la mobilité je parle pour la vie au
quotidien bien sûr si on y ajoute la
mobilité ça sera aussi nécessaire vous
dites qu'il y a un transfert qui va se
faire avec la décarbonation qui fait
qu'on va encore plus avoir besoin
d'énergie électrique que par le passé
notamment pour je je dis très clairement
aujourd'hui les six réacteurs qui ont
été décidés annoncés par le président la
République après bien avoir bien eu du
mal à à le dire c'est pas suffisant nous
considérons nous au Sénat c'est pas si
ce qu'il faut c'est 14 on sait le temps
l'APSE de temps qu'il nous faut pour
construire entre le moment où je décide
de faire une centrale de faire un
nouveau réacteur de faire c'est entre 12
et 15 ans il nous faut les femmes et les
hommes pour pouvoir être en capacité de
de le réaliser donc il nous faut un
véritable plein de relance et puis il y
a tout le nouveau nucléaire qui va
arriver les SMR ou les Small modular
réacteur oui sont des petits réacteurs
c'est ça là-dessus vous saluez le le
fait que le gouvernement les ait lancé
même s'ils ne sont que 6 et non pas 14
il y a quand même une une volonté
politique vous le reconnaissez ah mais
je la défends et je la soutiens depuis
le début elle va pas assez loin elle va
pas assez loin il faut aller plus loin
parce que d'ailleurs c'est une solution
aussi pour des territoires qui sont pas
non interconnectés je pense au au
territoir deremè c'est des solutions
aussi en terme de transport parce qu'on
parle la production énergétique mais il
faut le transporter il faut transporter
à la fois l'électricité ou si on parle
du gaz du gaz vert il faut aussi le le
raccorder et le transporter et ça c'est
ce sont des investissements très lourds
qui doivent être prévus en concordance
avec la PPE merci Quentin merci Orian je
reviens tout à l'heure dans le club on
évoquera le projet de loi immigration
puisque l'examen est terminé en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale il
arrive en séance lundi et ce sera
évidemment à suivre avec vous on va
aller chez vous pour terminer dans
lesvuges Daniel grémier voir l'actualité
dans votre département on trouve cine
Catherine pardon plidon merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directrice
départementale de VUG matin Catherine
vous allez nous parler de la visite du
ministre de la Santé Aurélien Rousseau
attendu à l'hôpital de Remirmont un
établissement sous le feu de l'actualité
oui bonjour Effectivement Aurélien
Rousseau est venu ce lundi à l'hôpital
de
romirmont voir un petit peu les élus les
les soignants qui ont
traversé une une zone de de fortes
turbulen ces derniers
mois en raison du manque d'effectif et
puis en raison également de une série de
plaintes déposées par des des familles
de de de patients et des patients voilà
donc pour rassurer rassurer les
soignants et et confirmer que cet
hôpital était était vital pour le
territoire que vous inspire la visite du
ministre Daniel grimier
bonjour pour moi est essentiel
effectivement il est important de
rassurer il est important d' porter la
clairvoyance par rapport aux
interrogations des familles qu'il faut
et je suis vraiment heureux qu' a eu
cette rencontre avec les familles elle
était nécessaire et il est nécessaire
aussi d'apporter une réponse d'avoir la
lumière sur effectivement les
situations qui sont vécu avec beaucoup
de douleur pour ces familles donc c'est
un point qu'il faut vraiment aborder
l'autre point qu'il nous faut aussi
aborder l'hôpital d'une manière globale
en France fr mais pas que dans les Voges
en France mais on a une situation très
particulière pour le département
desvoges l'hopitan soigne l'hopitan
sauve des vies l'hopitan nous permet de
mieux vivre donc je voudrais pas non
plus qu'on oublie cet aspect des choses
et ce travail au quotidien qui est
réalisé y compris à l'hôpital de
remiermont est au service de nos
territoirees et il était effectivement
essentiel d'avoir ce dialogue avec les
équipes il faut le retrouver confiance
il faut retrouver une certaine dynamique
au niveau des services il faut sûrement
alléger le système administratif dans
les hôpitaux pour consacrer plus de
temps et de moyens à soigner et de
d'enlever un peu de complexité
administrative là on a eu des exemples
très très évidents qui montrent qu'on
peut être bien plus efficace et avoir
plus de moyens pour soigner et puis il
faut relancer là encore euh un attrait
au métier dans les soins on l'a vu tout
à l'heure sur la psychiatrie mais d'
maère générale sur beaucoup de métiers
de santé de de personnes qui nous aident
à mieux vivre on est en souffrance par
manque de personnel et donc c'est une
situation très particulière moi je me
réjouis qu' a eu cette visite je me
réjouis qu' a eu cette confirmation
parce qu'on a tellement dit ou fait peur
en disant l'hôpital dormirement va
fermer la maternité dormirement on va
fermer et non il y a il y a un travail
en cohérence à établir entre l'ensemble
des établissements hospitaliers dans le
département desbauches en particulier
entre les plateaux d'Épinal et de de
Remirmont mais pas que c'est d'un merge
globale qu'il nous faut trouver de
l'efficacité qu'il nous faut rendre plus
euh je seraitant dire plus accessible
encore aux soins dans des conditions et
des calendrier raisonnable quand on voit
aujourd'hui la situation pour avoir
certains rendez-vous c'est tout
simplement pas
possible Catherine cet hôpital il est
vital pour pour les vauges mais
également pour la haute zone et
effectivement pour la la petite histoire
il a été inauguré en 1975 par Simon
veale qui était ministre de la Santé à
l'époque avec Christian ponelé qui est
qui est devenu président du Sénat par la
suite merci merci beaucoup Catherine
merci pour toutes ces précisions c'est à
la Une de VOG matin le message fort du
ministre de la Santé Aurélien Rousseau
qui est donc à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci Daniel grimier d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première dem